welcome back to las vegas now from
cheddar to mozzarella to parmesan there
should
be a type you enjoy right because today
is national cheese day
which is the perfect time to get cooking
in nanny bubby's kitchen she is
partnering with the wisconsin cheese
association to celebrate national cheese
day hey nanny bubby
hey rocky so happy to you know be here
with you i hope i get in the studio with
you
very very soon i hope so soon as well
friday we miss you too what are you
showing us today
happy national cheesecake i just want
thank you for sure it is i want to just
take a moment to be very very serious
here which
is i want to tell you that i've spent a
great deal of time
really my passion is to connect people
to our land and our food
and certainly we've done that with
vegetables and growing
but to really take a moment and honor
the men and women and their families who
are so
dedicated to dairy and bringing cheese
and especially wisconsin cheese
where they are not big batch factory
farm
cheese it is in most cases small batch
artisanal cheese and i'm just so proud
and that is the reason why i agreed to
do this segment with them
is just another connection to the food
that lands on our table
is usually given to us with great
sacrifices from these families so
with that we're making let's get let's
get cooking with cheese
right yeah thank you wisconsin i'm
seriously
now so listen this is fresh spinach
and this is some shredded basil so we're
just going to put that on top
we're going to just take a little bit of
lemon juice and olive oil
and just put it on oh my gosh we're
going to toss that
so fresh right so the basil's grown in
nanny bubby's garden
and we're going to take this and we're
going to start layering so we're going
to
throw this in the bottom here just like
this
and then we are going to take are you
ready are you
waiting for it ready we're gonna throw
strawberry yeah we're gonna throw
strawberries
in the bottom we're gonna throw some
yes it doesn't look beautiful and the
green and the red so beautiful little
tomatoes on top of that
and then we're going to take the
wisconsin wisconsin sorry
cheese balls which i've sliced in half
as i did
the tomatoes and the strawberries and
just put a layer of that
on top and then we're going to start
again we're going to start with the rest
of the spinach
so i'm only going to do this halfway in
the interest of time which i have come
because i was very aggressive and wanted
to do two recipes today
in honor of the dairy association of
wisconsin and wisconsin
and national cheese day who knew there
was such a day
right well there's a day for everything
so i'm not surprised
i'm looking at those cheese balls and
that's a good snack by itself
it is it absolutely is thank you for
saying that
okay so that would be how we start to
layer and i'm just gonna there's my
um syllable that's chapman right can't
say that enough
and then i just want to show you the
very end
of what that looks like so you see how
that's layered
and we've sprinkled a little bit of
basil on top like that
and we're going to just set this over
here on the side
and um we're going to um let's
just have intern megan take that and now
what we're doing is we're making an
asparagus tart
so let's yeah look at this so do you see
this these onions i pre-cooked
and i know isn't that great
i know that smells good oh my god it
smells like um
onion cream of mushroom soup so anyway
you're going to put this
right right thank you and we're going to
put this right on top
this has onions cream and
um parmesan cheese melted which i had to
do in the interest of time prior to you
guys all getting here right
of course and you can take notes too
because the ingredients are on the
screen everybody
oh thank you and also this is a puff
pastry uh puff pastry shell
and you get this in your freezer section
of any grocery store
everybody has it okay we've got a minute
to get this done and believe it or not
this is so easy
that actually we are going to be done in
that one minute so ready last
and out and
we are going to take asparagus and we're
going to line it up and even if i don't
get done you'll watch and see
that through the magic of television it
actually gets done
this goes into the oven at about 3 50.
there we go and yeah it looks so simple
i always feel very inspired like i can
do this too
you can do it rocky you really can i
want to give you the cooking confidence
to know that you can i want
everybody to know that they can so
with that we're going to take this and
we're going to pop it in the oven
and then and
look at that there it is we're going to
finish it off
with a little bit of parmesan cheese and
so you can see
right here and then we're going to zest
it we're going to zest
oh i can't get that out i can't get it
out my hands are too slick
we're going to zest a lemon on top i
just got it
we're imagining it we're imagining it
we're tasting it thank you so much
we say thank you on normal days we say
go out and spread love like butter but
on national tuesday we say
go out and spread cheese like butter i
love it spreading love either way
all right thank you so much nanny buffy
you can tune in to more recipes and
get more information about nanny bubby's
kitchen and garden on social media or
online at nannybubby.com we also want to
thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring the
segment